Battle Royale everyone loves playing it
publishers love making better oil cooler
judy has won a peck Legends is basically
trying to hold battle royale for tonight
change to a battle royale and pub G is
obviously the one that kicked off the
whole trend but there is one series
which is a very popular first-person
shooter that doesn't have better Royale
in its sights just yet but maybe should
Eddie what are we talking about yeah so
there's a lot to unpack here the halo
series is one of my favorites and I love
Battle Royale games as well so all this
discussion about Battle Royale it's
really got my interest in to see you
know what can happen with Halo in the
Battle Royale space so most recently
Bonnie Ross the head of 343 did an
interview where one of the subjects that
came up was you know naturally Battle
Royale cuz : of the biggest trends in
gaming today and her comment basically
was that they're developing a new engine
slipspace which is technically capable
of doing all manner of new things one of
which would be battle royale and you
know while she's not confirming anything
at this stage it's intriguing to think
about how better al could be applied in
a halo sensibilities and the Halo
franchise overall yeah so obviously halo
is known for its great team deathmatch
and it's great deathmatch modes but they
have branch tanta sort of other styles
of multiplayer shooter like for example
the warzone mode was basically a MOBA
style or MOBA influenced mode where you
were controlling points get vehicles you
were like pushing forward with other
troops and obviously there's the forge
where people are making their own you
know like little games with Halo sort of
toolkit but 343 has previously said that
they are not interested in Barrow is
that true yes so the comment that came
out like it's all been very fluid it was
they do like the handle guys do like a
social stream every Friday and one of
the comments that came out was really
funny to think about now is the only BR
we care about is the battle rifle which
is like it sounds hillarious now and
very silly but Bonnie Ross said later
that you know apex legends it was more
of a use case for what a battle royale
could look like in the Halo universe and
that's really interesting because those
original comments about you know better
ale not being something they were
interested in came from you know when
only fortnight was around the scene and
obviously pub G as well but for tonight
was the the biggest game of that time so
I think it's really interesting to think
about when
like halo with its you know great
weapons great vehicle it's great
team-based play there like you said do
you think a halo a battle royale
actually needs vehicles because when I
think of Halo multiplayer and the good
times with Halo multiplayer I think of
like hectic arena like shooting like
lots of jumping you know a long time to
kill a lot of hectic fun when you throw
the equals into the mix like Halo
vehicles just seem invincible in my mind
yeah they are they can be pretty Opie
especially some of the larger ones so I
guess yeah that's a good point I think
you would they would have to be you know
the faster ones the less lethal one you
know more for traversing the map and
getting from point A to B faster and
then making it a risk/reward scenario
where you can zoom across the map but
everyone's gonna see you and Halo has
the you know the planes and helicopters
and things like that too so that would
add a different level of like
verticality to battle rail games that
doesn't really exist today obviously
there have been a lot of battle royale
games come out not just the big ones a
lot of smaller ones have come and gone
some have comes kind of just like
bubbles under the surface but the really
great better rails always have a big
cook so pub G has it's like ultra
realism 49 has its building apex has its
movement system and the squad based
tactics and the fact that you're forced
to play with other people
what would halos battle royale have I
guess one of the criticisms of battle
rail games is you launch and there's you
know one map or there's you know a very
limited amount of you know locations and
things to do which is not to say those
worlds aren't totally fleshed out but
with Forge and that kind of playground
slash you know sandbox that they have if
players have the tools to you know
create their own custom maps and do all
these wild and wacky things within the
framework that 343 creates I think that
could be really exciting and make it
just a different experience every time
you play it and you know some maps say
they're made by the community some maps
wouldn't be as fun some would be great
and they would get uploaded or
downloaded so I'd love to see just a
higher refresh rate and in terms of
where the where the weapons are what the
map looks like all of that could be
theoretically
changed on the fly within forge and that
would at least for me would definitely
keep me coming back all the time right
so it's like fortnight's sort of
creative yeah
Aylin thing mashed into one big map so
basically you're better whale map is
made up of like 12 different Forge maps
and it rolls random wage that would be
amazed now that was really cool and very
strange in Halo 5 right now there was no
official battle royale mode but people
have made it themselves part of the
experience for me in battle royale games
is I know I'm not always going to win
but the sense of accomplishment
within each match I think would be
really important so I'd like to see them
do whatever kind of mini tasks within
that and when you consider how sprawling
and massive the Halo franchise is I
would imagine there's just so many
opportunities they have there whether or
not it kicks off remains to be seen but
I also think another at like element is
that the Halo franchise has been kind of
on the downturn for the past few
releases and it's getting less popular
armor it's become less popular so I
think Microsoft's their back is
obviously not up against the wall it is
a huge franchise everyone still knows
halo but a battle royale mode could be
the thing to say look it's gonna draw
new players and those people who come in
you know might stick around for the
campaign might stick around for the
traditional head-to-head multiplayer
right that's what I'm thinking about I'm
thinking about Halo infinite as a
package that has campaign multiplayer
and better way out and you know how they
to split their resources like that but
if they were to pull an apex legends and
just release a completely separate
product would that be a smarter move
yeah it might be you know because if you
if you do it that way then it's
completely detached and devoid of the
actual franchise yeah and one needs
character as well you know because like
apex Legends isn't as goofy as fortnight
but it has character it has like
backstories distinct sort of phases when
we talk about halo you talking about
spawn you talk about a helmet you talk
about military grunts and the covenants
there was an intriguing report recently
that said the halo infinite is going to
have more RPG mechanics and more
character customization so if that is
indeed the angle that they're going with
you could imagine being able to you know
create and customize a person with new
weapon skins you know new dances new
emotes being able to build out your own
character and make them more uniquely
you is something that Halo franchise
could really do with and in Battle
Royale
that could actually be a great way to
apply that
okay so those are all the reasons we
think halo should add a battle royale
mode in the future remains to be seen if
it'll happen we're going to learn a lot
more about the game at e3 so keep
checking back with GameSpot for more
[Music]
you
[Music]